[Music]
gonna realize the game that must be my
cue to go and start talking right so you
guys welcome to logo design review today
we're talking to Marcus wrench I hope
you guys are seeing me live on YouTube
we'll get this picture thing worked out
a little bit but what we're doing today
is we're talking about logos you love or
more like logos you love to hate so
we're gonna get into redesigning a
famous logo and of course I mentioned at
the top of show it's gonna be Marcus
French and here's how you get in touch
with him he's that wrench that design
and he's from humbug humbug Germany and
this is some of his work you guys are
very familiar with who is if you've been
watching his channel because he and a
deal used to kind of do the logo therapy
session but as you know now we're doing
something a little bit different and the
logo he's chosen to redesign is CD
Projekt RED these are supposed to be
famous logo so I asked Marcus right
before we went on air I didn't know who
this company is and he's gonna have to
tell us who they are and why he picked
them but we're gonna see what he's done
with this so Marcus tell us why why this
company what's wrong with them
what's going on yeah hi everybody
first of all I wanted to say what
company did choose so you already heard
it that I'm gonna say it anyways what is
it was a tough decision I choose CD
Projekt RED so you said before Chris you
don't even know who that is
so I'm gonna say who is CD Projekt RED
it is a badass video game developer
right from Poland they have their
headquarters in Wausau and they make
just awesome games they're driven by
passion and I think I make myself clear
do I need to have to say more alright
alright okay okay here we go sir so
you're a gamer that's why you'd ask and
logo does it bother you do people hate
this logo um I don't think I hate it I
don't hate it either but I think you can
do it a bit better okay so yeah so like
you see here
they made the awesome which is serious
the latest game which a while and this
is probably the best RPG ever made can
you share your screen Marcus yeah we
can't see it I was like maybe it's me
okay
sorry no no no we're it's because I was
sharing my screen earlier okay yeah and
by the way it seems like a lot of the
audience knows whose CD Projekt RED is
so it's a lot of gamers out there I feel
like I'm gonna start again so alright I
hope no you can see my screen yep okay
that's better okay yes okay like like I
said before they made the awesome wishes
serious which a Wyatt I'm probably the
best RPG and the world hands down just
finished his masterpiece and it was
truly here experience and they're
currently working on cyberpunk 2077 I
think that is the most hype game
recently and also they are known for
cuenta cuenta so one very famous cut
game you can play inside when you play
which oh so it was so popular they made
did their own game okay and so I why did
I choose CDP are simply put they're just
different you see all games they they
make or distribute are completely DRM
free as oh that means digital rights
management free you can copy the games
you can run them revolt discs or you can
burn them on this something like that
and that is a huge step forward I think
and they also are part of their own
capital group called CD project as a and
they also own their own digital
distribution platform called GOG calm or
good old games so what this means is
because they're part of this capella
group they have they have money they
a stable financial condition on the
market so they can concentrate on what I
can do best
developing awesome video games and
providing games with access to everyone
so they can publish and distribute their
own games so there is no greedy
publisher behind them who forces them to
fraud unfinished games every year and
they got time because making a video
game takes time and making an awesome
game takes even more time that's like
you're a little bit of a fanboy I'm the
fan I just discovered we as I said which
are free and finish there I already I
had this game for several years on my
harddrive but I never played it I don't
know why and then I watched Netflix show
last year I found it so good that I
wanted to give it another try
and I started which are free and it was
just a blast
I'm completely in love with this with
this game so that is why I picked this
company because I wanted to have a
personal connection with the company or
brand something that I use love so nice
datos y pictum so so what's the meaning
of their logo okay you see north and
Cardinals little bird you can see here
under the left it's cute little bird and
this that is what they see themselves in
a gaming industry it is intrepid it is
full confidence flying high and aiming
even higher and the color the cardinal
red is something that connects with
another bird from the Slavic mythology
it's called der Eric it's very close to
to their cultural roots and this is a
small deer Eric is a small fire bird who
believed to bring luck to people
so this red also stands for energy and
the inner fire that burns in every
single member of these of this games to
you so that is what drives them forward
they put all their effort to make the
best RPGs in the world and you can say
they are free like a bird because they
are not in need of big publisher for the
games right I am their ball they're
fearless even rebellious and have their
fourth passion and energy does and that
is that is the fire that is burning
inside of them so that is their the
identity that is their story like one of
my favorite logo designers used to say
and logo design is not about
communication it's about identification
and I think it's exactly that what we
have to see here so here's a short all
of you over there are guidelines you see
the logo itself on the right and then
they toast their two colors the cardinal
red that is the pen $21.99 see and then
they use just plain simple black as font
they use the proxy manova that is a
pretty-looking salsa reef and they
already they used or i use this this
font in their logo type and they
customize that a bit with those sharp
angles you see so it absolutely makes
sense to me right why why I want to
change that you might ask yeah well yeah
it is beautiful but it has way too many
details so when you shrunk it down
it works barely on small sizes right so
and I bet you haven't even seen as I
there is a little eye inside this bird
and I can tell you oh boy this is a very
angry looking bird so the way too many
details and also simple black-and-white
anyone I mean that is the monochrome
version right there on the right but
what if you can't use shades well like
if you just want to put your I don't
know your logo and stitch it on some cap
or I don't know like that is something
that also kind of borrows me and also
the logo type itself is seems like a
kind of floats in the air because there
are so many sharp angles on the letters
legs it's not necessarily a bad thing
but I think we can can change that or
fix that so in short the good and the
bad the good it's an awesome
storytelling right it Nance the
company's cultural roots perfectly that
is the identification those are their
roots and the logo itself was bold was
confident and very impactful high high
contrast very good but the bad is it's
way too complicated there is no clean
black and white version and it works not
good on small sizes so the question is
so I'm gonna change this or how gonna
try to fix this and because like I said
before the the identity and their story
is clear that is something that is just
beautiful and works very very nicely so
that is a thing I don't want to touch
and I also don't want to change the
overall concept so what we gonna do is
we're gonna change the look but not the
idea we stay true to ourselves so that
is also the goal to make it simpler to
make it work on small sizes but to
maintain their values but also to keep
the general concept so those are the
first steps
and now I'm gonna show you my ya
sketching process in this yeah I already
used before I well before I even start
in Illustrator I just start with simple
pen and paper we shall share them we're
still in the keynote deck I think no
just not started right oh yeah so okay
okay when I'm sad right here so yeah
just made a time-lapse of my sketching
process and I started to just make some
explorations with the head of the bird
played around with a bit of negative
space which which is kind of interesting
but then I decided to dead is would be
better to just show the whole bird's
body and a position like he spread his
wings open up in the sky so he has some
sort of position like come at me bro I'm
a rebel I'm free and a bird
I'm sure that's what the bird is saying
come at me bro yeah all right I like
seeing your sketching process though
this is the first for the show and that
we're actually seeing pencil sketching
with hands and pencils yeah thanks so
this is see ya final sketch I made and
what I'm gonna show and those are my all
my explorations I did not in a specific
order but we're gonna keep are we gonna
take the top left and go into
illustrator I kind of like also number
three in that grouping there that was
pretty nice as well something to think
about I have a question for can you
bring it back that last image please
okay sketch
that's right mm one moment and oops
right around I hear but that I have a
question for you I I often try to draw
animals and birds and things like this
using very geometric simple shapes but
they always wind up not looking like the
animal are you studying the animal first
before you draw or how are you able to
capture the essence of an animal an icon
and of course I tried to look up four
pictures of the animal I want to draw
but also if you just don't have some
time or patience you just check trouble
for those logo designs from anymore sort
of off animals because when you type
bird in or on triple or Behance you're
probably you can get a lot of results
just from awesome designers who did a
lot of logo explorations any good style
it also is some kind of inspiration for
me okay
all right continue I'm pleased ok so now
we're going we're going to ask og to do
there we go
jump right into illustrator and before I
start just wants to say it's very hard
for me to come recreate my logo
construction and process completely from
scratch again
to record it so please forgive me I just
want to show you each layer step by step
I'm gonna show you each layer one after
another so we can have to see what I did
and I also see peas for this because
people do want to see the process
because it's uh it's always a big gap
between seeing a real photo and then an
intention and then seeing the finished
product so please take your time and
share it exactly ok so I put my sketch
here on the top left and a little
picture of the Northern Cardinal beneath
so we always we can see what we have to
do here to deal with
case or set up my basic grid mm I always
use the illustrator default grid but
always make sure to when you use the
default weight to make sure that you
enable the function snap to grid as well
because if you haven't then this whole
illustrator default code doesn't make
sense right so I'm setting up my smart
guides here for my basic construction
and you can already see I have hits its
head it's it's body and now I'm gonna
set some single circles and lines here
on its head because I want to make a cut
out which will be some kind of negative
space in the later logo mark because
that is the area where the you can see
here if you look at the northen cardial
it has this black Pharaohs around his
face and that is some sort of negative
space I want to use in my later logo
mark so no I'm just convert all my smart
guides back to normal apps just gonna
show you that is the basic construction
and I'm gonna fill that with a shade
with grey I'm gonna go with a basic grid
and that is or complete logo mark so far
it's the first step so the second step
is to Martin using Pathfinder to do
convert all the shapes into the mark
that you drew not not necessarily yeah I
just - mostly I just try to fuse those
saying
pass manual together so I have in total
control of what's going on because
sometimes when you just I don't know
just mark some of the spaces and then
hit the button and it fuses or it all
together it often creates some
unnecessary anchor points and stuff and
I don't like that so there's something I
not always do wait so I'm unclear how
did you create their shapes from just
drawing lines then my tech D okay wait
let me show you that the same question
that Dan skis asking Chris is it I don't
know so yeah but he was showing you my
stuff everything and then magic and it
was a bird yeah at the heart
wait a minute when did that happen so
basically I you see all those lines and
I just delete all those anchor points
from those circles for example so I get
the upper left or right part of the
circle and then I hit the command
command and J I believe to fuse those
halves together so I behind idli enough
hi can you see this is a live file right
nope it's not it's not just a video just
recording me I thought your like live
clicking on all these things okay okay
delete those points in joining okay so
everybody who may or may not be
following what's going on let me just
explain what's going on Marcus really
likes to have control over his his
geometry and he doesn't like extra
extraneous points and you will get those
if you use pathfinder or shape builder
you get a lot of straight points most of
us will go back in and clean those up
but he was like you know what I want to
do it that way so what he's doing is
he's going in editing the circle and
deleting it with the direct selection
tool so that he gets the back half of
the curve and then we're points overlap
these circles are selects both points
and hits command J to connect them and
it makes a wooden path so he's being
very intentional all right thank you
yeah guys I gotta head out you on the
pre-recorded video keep going
okay so jump a little floor okay
yeah so there was the first step now for
the second step I wanted to make a
custom font because like I mentioned
earlier those very sharp angles they use
on their logo type makes it kind of
float in the air and I just wanted to
try to make something on my own
so I thought it would be a great thing
to search for a very condensed font and
I found this font called Abel it's
available in google fonts but the bad
thing is it's only available in one in
one font style so there's no problem for
us because we just wanna we just gonna
create our own font style make it
thicker so in order to do that we start
with we make a path out of this font and
we activate our smart guides and then we
gotta measure this exact width of this
letter so we're gonna need those numbers
later and then make a then make a copy
of this letter paste it and take it up
into the front fill it with a good read
and then it create an outline from it
and then I delayed the inner outline
once I did this I take this offset path
or this path this outline a copy those
numbers from the wif make an offset path
remember okay and just hit exactly this
number we measured and to get the exact
offset path in the middle right between
those two outlines we divide
this number by 2 so we get exactly the
health of the lettuce with that is a
basic structure we're going to use for
or later exploration okay it's a really
it's a really fast and simple way to
customize your own font okay so now I'm
gonna recreate this step for every other
letters in our logo type which I
prepared you can see it here okay and
then we take one of those offset paths
like two P here and then we make a
second offset path now we can define the
new width or for a new font style I want
to make it thicker so just typed in
three and a half pixels somehow kind of
look good and click OK and that's
basically everything we have to do in
order to make our phone more thicker so
I created these steps with all the other
letters the logo type and you can see
how the oval font become much bolder and
now what I'm going to do is like I'm
setting up some angles to for the
cutouts because I also wanted to keep
that idea of those sharp angles they
used for the current logo type so I used
45 degrees angle and also this angle
from decay here so I can fit it nicely
in to the tee but just those few letters
get these sharp angles and then
basically we just fuse all
offset pass in one shape with the of the
angles cut out so this is all fine logo
taught and the last thing I did was to
make some lower make some kerning or
that are spacing so I just choose to
choose the width of 10 pixels and you
can you can align all letters and say
that it should be all that is exactly
the same width of 10 pixels but then you
know kerning you have to figure out what
letters you have to reduce the
whitespace in order to balance
everything optical optical nicely out so
that is what I did here there's no
correct mathematical theory or rule here
I think you just have to trust your eyes
okay
looks good are okay D and this is the
trademark symbol so that is our final
logo type and I think it still has this
vibe going on which they have in their
current logo type so know we have those
things logo mark and a logo type and in
the last step we're gonna fuse those
together and place it in one file okay
I'm just gonna I'm gonna start with the
logo mark inside this is grid and then
I'm set some smart guides to define some
spaces there's a common rule you can
apply here just to define the head of
your logo type you just take the half of
your logo marks height in order to have
a good ratio between logo mark and logo
type and I thought it would be a good
fit to place the logo type on in this
exactly hate because there's this wing
coming down it's perfectly aligned with
the logo type once I did that I define
the clear space it's the same rule here
it's half the head of the local mark
like logo mark itself six six and the
clear space is free x or x and also the
space between logo mark and logo type
it's 1x so this is something I always do
when I am finishing up on my logo files
to define them a basic written also some
clear space in order to yeah so that the
logo truly can
work because when you don't define clear
space and such things and you deliver
the file to the client he will use the
logo wrong so there's always something
you have to consider when you prepping
up your logo files and that's somehow my
process kind of quick I know but just
wanted to show you guys oh what's going
on in my own files yeah it was nice to
see you take a typeface and then modify
it a kind of interesting process not one
that I would do and I'm just very
interesting to see how you took a
typeface and modified it to relate to
the angles from the icon that you've
created I noticed a couple things I just
want to take a moment to tell everybody
this that what is I called mono with
typefaces or you could apply this to
ones that aren't you may mono stroke
meaning that it's even throughout the
stroke in terms of its width you could
use the trick that Marcus just shared
with you I think some of the comments
here and in the 400 plus people that are
watching was like a very interesting
process how you modified the letter form
I do want to say this as a public
service announcement for all designers
here you have to be aware that the
horizontal stroke has to be thinner in
the vertical stroke because otherwise it
looks too fat so mathematically they're
the same but optically they're gonna
feel too heavy and if you zoom into it
you'll see what I'm talking about just
let you guys know so the stroke the
horizontal stroke of the e the three
bars that go horizontally are relatively
too thick optically for what's going on
so I would go back in there and just
those things I think you need that with
the E and parts of the D and possibly to
C but since it's curved it may not
matter okay what else you got for us
okay
so that was my local process alright um
trying to type gently here because I
don't want to hurt my keyboards feelings
sorry okay
so that is the final logo oh now it
makes a lot more sense yeah yeah it's
like okay look at it they clean very
clean so when Marcus was drawing this in
the grey against a white background it
didn't have that contrast and a visual
punch and it felt like I was missing
something in the eye but I think he knew
that it was gonna be on black and then
it fills in the high and it's actually a
very striking mark it's very simple
well done there you gone thank you okay
yeah so here we CD before and after you
can see the proportions are clearly
different now in the old logo you can
see that the logo type is kind of small
compared to the logo mark now we're
going to fix we have to fix this now or
we had to fix this yeah also this is the
alternative version the portrait version
when you can see clearly that this logo
has its full potential when you use it
on a black background kind of works on
y2 but it truly has a full potential
when you use it on this dark surface so
this is also black and right and here is
some of my symbol meaning a breakdown of
the Dogu mark itself so what is the
meaning like we have this Northern
Cardinal what we try to accomplish with
this mark also its wings are in the
shape kind of a flame or fire
which symbolizes the passion and the
energy they have and also this
particularly opposition of the carnal
bird it's it's it's just like come at me
bro
he's rebellious he's free he's a rebel
he's independent saying come back you
know and yeah also this the combination
between north and cardinal and this fire
flame thing refers to the mythological
creature here the rock from the slavic
mythology so that is the symbol meaning
here are the clear space and the great a
black surface and also this is my
stylesheet I often try to create to
combine all things unpack it and pack it
in one single off on one single sheet
like the logo construction the logo
meaning the colors the used fonts and
what the logo is about of what something
about the brand or company itself so I
added one additional color to the black
and red it's called Pantone Pantone II
WOM WOM red and I didn't know if you
noticed that but I put a very very
subtle gradient inside the logo mark
because it adds a little little death to
it especially on black surface and this
is my exploration board was I call it
fun board rare I just throw in all my
shapes and explorations and type down
stuff I'm thinking about what I can do
better what is good what is wrong and
that is like something I think you have
to make in order to to break through to
just to be free and try different things
out
and just j-just let your credit
creativity run wild so I wondered and
questions yeah yeah oh no in real life
now are we doing mock-ups both okay
let's see how this works in real life or
best part applications or mock-ups
you're right Chris so I started with the
website this is screenshot from their
actual website from the normal desktop
version also from the mobile version you
can see it works beautiful even as a
favicon in a web browser and they also
have own merchandise store where they
sell merchandise from of their
franchises like cyberpunk were Witcher
so I made an alternative version for
this role as well just for the stores so
they can put this logo on their store
and I thought it would be very cool to
have to have their own app for the store
so talking about merchandise right so
I'm going to show you some merchandise
okay hey they could even put their own
logo mark on t-shirts which they could
sell I would buy it I'm honest with you
it works even beautiful on a label or
you could made hints out of it every
like those with ammo pins and they pop
out yeah me too thanks its yeah
something where they could improve their
current state like to merchandise their
own brand identity or
anymore so people would buy this also
games right because they publish games
they make games and this is some of the
game copies which a white hand recently
came out for a switch to complete
edition very good game even on switch
beautiful
so can use it on science or they could
use a logo mark on I don't know like I'm
some sort of Easter Egg inside of their
own games they did it before in The
Witcher and I could that they could do
that even in the new from game name
currently I'm working on in cyberpunk or
even bigger science like this this could
be on their office right so works great
here too so I think daddy that's it so
thank you very much and before I'm done
I wanted to say thank you to our guys
from the future thank you Chris thanks
to other guys thanks thank you what do
you what are you doing for this
community putting out all this awesome
content it's amazing
very very grateful to have this chance
to show off my work my process a very
truly great experience so thank you and
thank you also CD Projekt RED for being
just there for being awesome and making
just awesome games so alright what is it
thank you good job okay alright I want
to do a little little analysis and
critique I think in the past people have
said hey we want to hear your thoughts
on this so as with a deal I'm gonna do
the same thing with you Marcus well
congrats great job and whenever we see
the logo live in space and see how its
applied it's just it comes to life again
if you're not doing mock-ups to present
you your clients you may be selling
yourself a little bit short clients
don't have that imaginary
so it takes me back to my corporate
identity days when I was in school doing
the mark is sometimes work and it's
painful but doing the applications
strong the uniforms designing the trucks
and the packaging that was like really
really fun
you got to let your creativity loose and
there were there are many questions that
I have about this marking so when I get
right into it
first of all mark can you help me
monitor some of the comments and see if
they want to ask Marcus any question
before I start digging in now luckily
Marcus sent me looking files so I have
some files to look at this time some I'm
gonna dig into the files in a second so
it markets let's answer some questions
or any questions that we need to address
it first see there's a lot of good
comments here a lot of people love the
redesign I think other comments were
just kind of commenting on CD Projekt
RED his company they hope you get this
job because they're a big company and
apparently they're one of the leaders in
the Warsaw Stock Exchange so like you're
saying they've got some some money as
far as the design goes someone is asking
specifically about the red contrast is
it enough to go against the black
background I think that's just more of
an aesthetic question what do you think
Chris okay sorry I thought you can ask
Marcus I'm right now so ask target well
yeah someone was asking like there's the
red contrast well with the like well
against a black background
oh yes yes yeah you know classic color
combination is white black and red just
awesome color combination used a lot of
different places I don't want to mention
where but you know you're familiar with
this color palette it's very striking
it's probably the most powerful color
combination I know of red black and
white and we had another question in
regards to kerning and when you were
doing all of the the manual kerning
there what was your sort of rationale
behind how much space you're putting
good question I just started with ten
pixels by default and figure something
out what looks kind of great I try to
refer to the old logo type they use they
have a candy very
white running or much Lobos the space
kind of letter space between each single
letters so I used that too yeah
or Internet me too to look it up but
then I had no an specific process behind
it just figure it out by myself
woof yeah with my eyes I don't know how
to describe this sorry there's there's a
trick for kerning if you guys ever want
to work out kerning and somebody
mentioned in the comments I read this is
you take your thing you think it looks
great and one way to fool your mind is
to flip it upside down 180 degrees and
then turn and then flip it back and then
turn it again and keep doing that till
you feel like it's right and it's it's a
it's part arts it's part science there
isn't a formula you have to do this
optically it takes a little bit of time
to train your eye okay
having said that I'm ready to jump in
here are we ready to do this so I'm
gonna do this right now I'm going to
share my screen and so Marcus I'm gonna
take over control here okay yeah where's
my own stuff this is the file that Mark
is sent to us which pretty awesome it's
all here and apparently I'm missing this
typeface cable and proxy manova Chris
doesn't have proxy manoa installed
get over it I have a question for you
Marcus the psychic on you you included
did you draw these to be blog and it is
that's how violent it he's flexing on us
right now he's like you know what not
only am I going to draw all the mark I'm
gonna draw a little icon set to WHO and
it looks really good just to kind of
strengthen the presentation I think
that's a really smart decision that you
did there do you always do something
like that when you're presenting yes
because a very love my King icons so III
know that they're mostly designers who
are tuning in but there are also some
companies and some some smart
entrepreneurs that are starting out that
are watching our channel because they're
curious about how
work with designers so if you liked this
work make sure you look up Marcus will
include his information in the the
comments below make sure you check that
out and I would be flashing his URL once
more in a little bit
I think it's wrench dot design is that
right yeah that is right
I didn't screw that up okay so you can
expect more things like this if you go
check out his work so those of you that
are curious go check it out you know my
first comment was when I saw you
designing this as gray on white it
didn't feel like the cardinal because I
think the blackness of the eye is such a
distinct part of the character so when
you popped it on black I'm like oh the
Cardinals they're exact same shape but I
think we need this part so one of my
suggestions would be in the in the white
version I think a black shape needs to
be there
now I'm gonna butcher your design just
one second okay so I'm this like this
and I'm gonna just draw I'm gonna copy
this this angle copy paste in front okay
so it's the same angle and I'm gonna
quickly give it a shape and I just want
to see how this is gonna look and see if
it changes the character or not so so
bear with me everybody let me cut this
ice in front change to the default
colors here and go like that and people
are saying hey we want you to do this
alive trust me you don't want to see us
doing this live because there's a lot of
weird decisions that are being made and
maybe I'm going to prove to you why you
don't want to do it live because I
probably messed up so I think the
pre-recorded video is a really good
alternative which allows you guys to see
the design as it takes shape but we can
spare you of some of the little mistakes
I'm like pecking around trying to figure
out what worth what that quirk trying to
do okay so I just think that for some
reason how I mean that blackness in
there it's going to help this bird read
as a cardinal and I'm realizing right
now maybe the wing has to be black too
let me further butcher your design but
let me just what happens and that's good
tell me in the comments probably Chris
stop doing this I hate you but a do it
anyways because design is about
curiosity and asking yourself those
you have questions okay so I for for
comparison's sake we're gonna take this
I have to unlock this again I'm gonna
take this I'm gonna scale this guy down
I'm gonna put it left and right
okay nothing right I'm gonna bring this
one a little closer so we can see a
little bit better and then now I'm gonna
go and delete these things and see oops
oh did I do something weird okay there
we go so as drawn against white and is
to color option I believe even if Marcus
doesn't love this he could also provide
a two color option for the claw eye I
think one of his criticisms was if you
want to embroider this if you want to do
something else with this will it work as
the one color design I love that kind of
thinking that kind of design discipline
that you're exerting on yourself or
making sure that you stay within those
constraints because a mark I in my
opinion needs to be able to be reduced
down to one color black and white
doesn't still work and he's proven that
it does so if we had the luxury of
adding gradients or additional colors I
think maybe adding the black really
allows me to see that that's a cardinal
it's a weird illusion but having a
little bit of the black you guys let me
know in the comments right now what do
you think
does it need the black does it not tell
me to go walk off a long bridge and take
a long walk off a short bridge or
something like that the last thing I
want to talk about is this is we were
talking about the width and this is
something I think we need to talk about
because this is happen with many of our
logo therapy sessions before where I've
stayed out of the critique part but I'm
gonna draw this let excuse me I'm gonna
draw this letter okay and if I were to
take this and that's the same width as
the vertical stroke but if I were to
take this and rotate it 90 degrees I
make a copy okay there we go and I were
to draw an E you're gonna see something
happen if I don't screw this up so I'm
gonna match it to right there
okay I'm gonna take this I'll bring it
up and I'll match it to that the logo
therapists have been really good at
explaining
really design principles you guys as
they're working on their design but if
you stare at this long enough you're
gonna start to see this horizontal
stroke this one I'm moving around feels
thicker than this vertical stroke and
it's just the way we see things and I
think designers like even back to the
Roman times started to figure out that
optical perception is more important
than mathematical perception and because
you look at it like it's a little bit ah
so this is what I'm talking about here
these strokes the vertical and the
horizontal stroke are exactly the same
and I want to prove it to you
I'll prove it to you I find a typeface
this is trade gothic bold condensed
number 20 okay
and I put it up here it's very similar
you know a similar vibe and there's even
din which I love this typeface it's not
as condensed this one that Marcus is
using and I'm gonna take a look at it so
if I were to take a look at this and hit
command shift o which is converted to
outline you're gonna see like okay does
it feel even to you especially if i zoom
out a little bit it probably does but
you're gonna see something different
you're gonna see the mathematical and
optical parts are different and these
are professional like world-class
designers who work on type faces and
this is a great way to learn if you if
you don't have the opportunity to study
under a master or even to afford books
or whatever or even time to watch these
kinds of videos just open it up your
typeface convert it to outline and study
it and see like what decisions were made
because after thousands of hours of
drawing type faces these designers have
learned something you see this right now
you see the difference between this
width and this one all right but you
know what that's a different style
typeface it's not exactly like this it's
true and if you look at another typeface
there's another one okay so this is ad
in middle shrift I think and I'm gonna
convert it to outlines I'm gonna do the
exact same thing - I'm gonna take the
vertical stroke I'm gonna measure it
like I'm gonna do right now and you guys
can let me know I'm boring you yeah we
get a Chris yawn yawn okay I get it
I just want to finish this and then
we'll never talk about this again until
the next episode let me rotate it I
haven't changed it at all there's no
magic here I'm gonna drop it here and
you're gonna see again okay and you're
gonna notice
about different parts to about how the
cake might hits with the the leg of the
cake and how it it's thicker or thinner
depending on what happens with the way
it's connecting to a vertical strum okay
that's it for this part I'm gonna try
and open this up and see if there are
any other questions mark are they any
questions people or I can't read the
comments right now so let me know if
they're saying something weird about
yeah well I'm just addressing going back
to the the horizontal versus the
vertical strokes there so just to be
clear here cuz people are wondering if
there's a standard or a rule to that but
from what you're saying it sounds like
it's more of an optical versus of
mathematical like absolutely it's an
optical thing that you need to adjust
you can say rule of thumb maybe 90% of
the thickness but it also has a lot to
do with the character of the typeface or
what you want to create some type faces
have much skinnier or narrower
horizontal strokes as they do vertical
strokes and when you get into more like
I think I'll show you an example right
now I'll show you an example I'm gonna
type it out again I'll type in a project
and I'll use all caps okay and I'm gonna
use Dido totally different kind of
typeface I'll do bold now you can see
with Dido the horizontal strokes mmm our
extremely skinny compared to the
vertical stroke and believe it or not
this is classified in as a modern style
typeface and depending on the typeface
the characteristics the the feeling the
vibe but you want to create you're gonna
see that's different so just be aware of
that now when you guys design this well
you guys designed this yourself just
make a decision like
optically just make it a little bit
narrower and you'll be fine I think the
other reason why this is a little bit
complicated is you have to take into
consideration the most commonly used
size of this typeface so those men for
text meeting using a book you want to
design it based on that size and that
usage versus a giant sign that's like 30
feet high so you're gonna need to adjust
the stroke based on the mode
commonly used application and it's gonna
be a little bit different
all right so that's an answer time okay
anything else before we get it out of
here you know there are major questions
but you're asking the audience whether
they like the black or not a lot of
people said no black okay that's fair
enough
so we're just on here oh they're like t
Marcus good good day yeah I'm just
exploring here what has a black face
that's the thing
but yeah questions about the word marks
versus the local mark and when you
should use both when you shouldn't have
one or the other
what are the what's a thought process
behind that there's no thought process I
mean you can see that the bigger company
is the more money they have for
marketing they start to move away from
the word mark and let me just show you
guys what we're talking about here I'm
gonna take this on the hide this one so
this is called a word mark it's made up
of letters okay and so when I bring this
back I'm gonna hide this now hi this
this is an icon the two together is a
combination mark that's a technical term
I believe and all of this is considered
a logo or logo type and logo type has
been used in exchange for trademark and
a trademark is something to let other
people know this is just not a generic
word this is the the proprietary or
copyrighted registered name of our
company register mark of our business so
do not copy it
okay so designers a long time ago
started to switch out the word trademark
with logo some logo is just this broad
umbrella term to describe any one of
these things okay did I help mark yep
all right another question for Marcus
how long did this take you and for you
what's a the right amount of time for
you to deliver something like this to a
client in question the question yeah I
think I worked last three weeks on
project since you guys asked me to take
this lava stream so I think three weeks
is a good amount of from from the idea
from sketching and to delivering the
final files for a single project so Wow
okay so it's not an overnight process
that takes some time hence one of our
other local therapist said ah it didn't
get to a place where he was happy so we
postpone that and it'll eventually
happened but it does take a lot of time
this is ya there in three minutes and
come up with something that you are
happy with okay mark any other questions
before we wrap up here we're good with
questions but I just want to remind
everybody if you have a lot of these
questions about the logo design our
course is on reduced tuition now so I'll
drop the link here in the comments but a
great overview it'll show you a lot of
these little specific things that you
guys been asking herself and we love you
guys interact with us and it started the
stream we had 150 people and now we're I
think we're around 500 people so that's
really cool I hope you guys enjoy this
and I'm going to then hopefully put this
thing up on the screen and it doesn't
flash but it's gonna flash it'll be
alright
the original mark which I thought was
pretty interesting bolding crazy with
this bird this Cardinal that is a head
explode or he's like ready to fight in
any marks is his word come at me bro and
the new mark which in this context looks
really clean modern bold and fresh so CD
Projekt RED if you guys are paying
attention maybe you you might consider
talking to Marcus if not for your logo
for something else and I think that's it
so on behalf of everybody at the future
team Marcus thank you very much thank
you for doing this or forgot I have a
slide here yeah this is how you get in
touch with Marcus don't mind the
blinking guys that's what we're doing so
Jonah cue the music let's get us out of
here and I hope you guys have a great
day
Jonah on the phone don't forget the like
comment and subscribe but now he cuts
away from our clapping figure
[Music]
the other this mission to cheat 1
billion people you guys are part of that
billion thank you very much for tuning
and watching with us if you want to
support the channel go and make a
donation
wonderful looping music orchestra riding
here
[Music]